definitivamente el ataque de esta mañana
a esta mezquita chiita en la población
de kandahar no es una buena noticia ni
siquiera para los talibanes ni para la
estabilidad regional los talibanes antes
de llegar al gobierno habían venido a
teherán una delegación y se habían
reunido con el gobierno iraní y habían
prometido proteger a esta comunidad
religiosa minoritaria que representa el
10 por ciento del país especialmente a
la etnia hazara que fue atacada ya en la
década de los 90 fuertemente cuando los
talibanes gobernaron el país y que luego
durante estos últimos 20 años ha sido
víctima de grandes atentados tanto
atribuidos a los talibanes como al
estado islámico de jorasán a quien
apuntan hoy todas las sospechas sin
embargo por lo que se puede ver los
talibanes no han podido garantizar la
seguridad de esa comunidad hace una
semana un gran atentado en la ciudad de
kunduz donde murieron
en citas y hoy vuelve a suceder este
atentado en la ciudad de kandahar que es
la ciudad más importante para los
talibán la que ellos dicen que protegen
y tienen por la seguridad totalmente
garantizada y hoy muchas voces desde
kandahar se preguntan bueno si no pueden
garantizar la seguridad en kandahar la
pueden garantizar en el resto del país
desde allí cuentan que en los últimos
días han aparecido banderas negras del
estado islámico de corazón en algunas
poblaciones de la provincia de kandahar
lo que hace temer aún más a la población
pasará hijita que se está yendo en masa
hay miles de ellos tratando de cruzar la
frontera hacia irán